hey what's up y'all it's Janelle Monae
check me out on the bootleg Kev podcast
show special guest in here
thank you for coming Janelle Monae thank
you for having me bootlegs
Kev yes I was telling you uh this album
that you have released it just came
first of all I heard you had a good time
last night celebrating I did uh I did
great album it feels like the summer it
feels like pool Vibes it feels like you
know barbecuing water
um alcohol
cannabis in the air yeah yeah well thank
you so much for listening yeah I I
definitely have vacation Vibes on my
mind I mean you're also in the water on
the cover so yeah you know it's all
about being I'm more like I will say I'm
like water these days you know
that's what life you gotta you gotta
roll like that
um for you like I think like you
obviously
we we know that like afrobeats is kind
of like
finally getting it's like just do
commercially but for you to have like
Egypt 80 on the project repeatedly
um they're kind of like the family that
started afrobeats yeah so uh I don't
think a lot of people know that is that
was that something like you consciously
wanted to do like kind of give them
their light because I think that was
pretty dope to have them on the album
yeah no shayun kuti who is the sun you
know if you guys don't know is the son
of uh Fela cootie who is just legendary
the founder of afrobeats the founder of
of so much of the music that we love
from the continent and
um
we had done like a couple shows together
and
you know he definitely is making his dad
proud but he's his own person and he's
just sick when it comes to Horn playing
and I was like I want to make sure that
we have his touch because it's important
to me that the diaspora is seen here you
know this is a super pan-african album
Blackness from every corner you know all
of my friends are from you know Ghana
Nigeria South Africa Jamaica Caribbean
and it's beautiful when our music you
know America North America
all of our music cultures can talk to
each other so that was that was
important on this album that you you saw
you saw this Melting Pot of like I guess
uh appreciation and love
um for for all things us and it sounds
like very good like it's it'd be like
some people try to pull stuff in and
it's like you know it just sounds like
like it sounds great in organic so I
agree love the album
um yo I wanted to ask you because
obviously are you from Kansas City
Kansas or Missouri Kansas City Kansas
are you like super hip to like because
on the other side of the Border there's
Casey MO and there's like Tech Nine is
like the biggest guy I love Tech N9ne
yeah I just wonder because I've been
doing Tech N9 for a long time we used to
be well he probably wasn't doing these
but I would remember performing at
events
um where he would be and
um performing talent shows that was all
I did 500 first prize and Tech N9 was
like always the guy in Kansas City yeah
he's still in this kind of it's crazy
it's legendary yeah I just always
because I was such a small place in
terms of like musically I think he's on
the Missouri side but we share a city
and we all I was always performed we
were performing at the same events we
would always somehow end up in the same
sort of studio with the same people yeah
I have a whole whole another past the
weirdos too that was another rap group I
used to be sort of in that group singing
We were like a more
um
I don't know like experimental uh fujis
oh wow yeah I like that I know the
weirdo we love the Fugees and we were
like how can we make it even more weird
you know when we did stuff together so
you know what um I realized too recently
because I just Revisited a
I Revisited Idlewild for like the first
time it feels like in like 10 years wow
cause I'm a huge Outcast fan I got
equipment right there yeah but that's
like the last real I guess body of work
we got from both of them and you're on
that body of work I am it's got to be a
big like do you ever like think like
damn I'm on the last Outcast album like
that everyone exists it's legendary
um they're legendary and just as people
I love them you know they they've always
been sort of like mentors to me big boy
did a lot for my career for sure you
know and and I always thank them and
then even artistically when you look at
outcasts you know they always
pushed something new you know you got
the the roots of funk and and what they
the way that they did it was super
Innovative and it definitely inspired me
to to to to to start wanting to when I
first started out to be comfortable and
confident uh in being unique I was gonna
say uh they did such a good job of
Reinventing themselves loves every album
and you've done a good job of kind of
Reinventing yourself every time you put
a new body of work out is that something
that because I think fans sometimes get
wrapped up in like liking their favorite
artists for like just this but I feel
like the greats like we think of
Kendrick yourself obviously Cass like
they always are Reinventing themselves
like every project like you know for you
is that something like do you always
want to make sure when you're putting
out a new body of work or you start
recording that you maybe experiment a
little bit more yeah yeah it's fun I
love the Journey of in evolving and
finding out new things about myself
discovering new things about what I can
do redefining that for myself on my turn
my own turn right
um I mean you know as artists you make
the rules so everything you know from me
today I literally made up those rules
that this is this is what I want to do
and you know this is how I'm living my
life at this time and it's always
beautiful to be able to honor where you
are at that time you can look back on
every album and like outward wow thank
you remember where I was where you were
yeah yeah yeah
um talk about because obviously I think
a lot of people don't realize that like
you have like an incredibly sick label
and like a guy like jidenna started with
you yes and I think Jordan is somebody
who is a [__] beast of an artist I
agree he doesn't get enough credit I
agree I kind of feel like classic man
was like a gift and a curse because it
was such a big record but yeah you gotta
dive into your dentist catalog yeah
super talented and he actually just
released a new album yeah he did he did
um I was gonna say like for you what is
your
um
when it comes to the label side and your
creative company what approach do you
take when it comes to finding Talent or
just working with somebody well right
now you know my career has taken off in
the time that I I'll just have to be
completely honest being an artist and
sort of having a label and then yes it's
a lot but even even you know even with
your dinner we're family you know like I
always I'm always like more so of a big
sister to him if he needs advice or if
he wants me to listen to a mix or if
he's like should this go on the album or
what do you think about this we talk and
and and business-wise if he needs advice
I'm there for him but for the most part
I like the artists should like be in
control of what it is that they're doing
I don't ever want to talk over that get
in the way of that
um and also be honest about just what I
can take on you know I think everything
is partnership level I think right now
you don't even need a label nobody needs
a list really you really don't I mean to
go straight to the people you can go
straight to the people obviously being
independent I've been in an independent
artist with no major label backing I
have my own label right and I know what
it's like to sell CDs out of your trunk
I know what it's like to live in a
boarding house you know working at
Office Depot selling CDs out of your
trunk like I totally get that and it's
you know it's hard it's difficult for
Independent Artists but um I think if
you you know you you can rewrite the
rules as well
um I was gonna say for you like you are
also like a huge actress
you are in I mean you what was the uh
Glass Onion well I would say the horror
movie Ranger like was it Annabelle oh
yes Antebellum yeah
um for you when you're in like acting
mode right because I know it's it's a
lot to to like act and like you have to
give your mental space to like being
someone else does it take away a lot
from the music like do you have to be in
like okay I'm turning down roles because
I'm working on music or can you do both
simultaneously
I think with music I have to be in the
studio and hands on with it I can't just
you know I need to be writing
collaborating living it you know
um touching it feeling it I Engineer a
lot of my sessions so even you're
running your own Pro Tools yeah well I
work out of logic oh oh yeah shout out
to live work out of logic yeah and I can
work out of Pro Tools but I prefer to do
logic um but yeah so just I need to be
super Hands-On with with music so I do
have to say no sometimes to you know
roles that may come in may come in and
sometimes that's difficult but music has
been so good to me a lot of the re the
you know I think that I got a lot of my
movie roles because of my music career
because people were able to see me and
go into different characters with Glass
Onion the movie I just got finished
doing
um Ryan Johnson said that he was like I
saw that you could be you could embody
these different characters and this is
what we need in this movie you know it's
because of your film for dirty computer
and seeing you in your different music
videos and I was like oh she can do this
so um I'm gonna always make time for
music yeah what was it like working on
set with uh the Craig guy the
007 Daniel Craig I love Daniel I love I
love he's so humble that's James Bond
ever he he killed as James Bond and he's
so much more though too like I did even
just talking to him that role that he
plays in those two movies yeah that man
amazing no his range is just incredible
seeing him go from that Southern drawl
to you know I'm Daniel Craig like the
British accent
um such a sweetheart the whole cast
Edward Norton I mean Fight Club was like
it's like my top five me too um Kate
Hudson all of them legendary yeah that
was a wild uh cast if you just like it's
one of those movies how much was the
budget for this movie right exactly
exactly no we we had a wonderful time we
shot that in Greece and in fact it
actually made me
get inspired to do this album I I shot
that film and in the same year I wrote
this album really was it because Greece
is like a Vibe low-key it was vacation
Vibes yeah it's like oh man like what
kind of what do I want to hear when I'm
here you know when I'm on an island I
mean I didn't pay to go there I mean
obviously the studio got me there and I
was just so inspired and I started
thinking about how I wanted to feel even
when I couldn't go on vacation I need an
album that sounds like you're on
vacation and I just knew my producer was
sending me music while I was on set I
was picking the the the drums and
different things and by the time I shot
glass onion I came back I already had a
musical bed so you were in the trailer
like yeah
I definitely wrote and plotted
um well I more so applauded a lot while
I was on set yeah has what has been the
uh most uncomfortable role you've played
as a uh as someone who acts because I do
feel like
there's a there's a lot that comes with
that gig you know you got to kind of die
I think Antebellum was tough yeah I
don't know if I'll ever do a role like
that again it was really tough to go and
be on a plantation and
you know play an enslaved person in
modern day times it was a lot on see
that seems deep it's heavy yeah it was
very heavy and it took a lot for me to
get that off of me too because
immediately after I wrapped my friends
were like let's go to Mexico and so I
was like well I need a vacation but I
couldn't shake that role and I would
just remember showing up
just like being super uneasy I'm like
girl what the [__] is wrong with you and
I'm like listen I lived basically lived
on the plantation for two months you
know I did it for my reasons to chant to
honor you know my ancestors and to bring
awareness
um you know to to a lot of injustices
but yeah I don't think I think that was
probably my hardest so when they say
like when you act you can like get into
the role I just saw um uh the guy who
plays Franklin State on snowfall say he
like channeled the devil to be Franklin
Saint in snowfall and he's like it like
it messed with him like after the show
was over a little bit yeah people don't
realize you're you're living and
breathing and I always you know stay out
into the universe like reduce Janelle
Monae I want you to see the spirit of
this character and and uh yeah a lot a
lot a lot of times it's hard to shake
those rows off uh somebody who you had
as a mentor which not a lot of people
can say is uh you rest in peace to
prince prince who's one of the greatest
creators of all time quite possibly the
most talented musician ever he's up
there in terms of the guitar he could do
it all how did you guys initially
connect well he
um with always this story just still
freaks me out and that freaks me out but
just I can't even believe
that it happened but he was supposed to
show up I was open opening up for
Raphael Saadiq this is yeah exactly my
first album in um
I get a knock after I get finished
performing and
you know I had this I remember I had a
sinus infection that day I was just like
loopy and this uh really really pretty
girl knocks on the door and she was like
I have somebody who wants to talk to you
and the girl was DJ Rashida who was
Princess DJ at the time but I didn't
know that that was right you know his DJ
and she just gives me the phone and then
I'm like hello and I'm like congested
and just like hello and he's like hello
Janelle
did you know right away and I'm like hi
who is this
this is Prince
Prince
yeah Prince I was supposed to come to
your gig but they gave me the wrong time
and I'm like
what like just freaking out or trying
not to because I don't want to embarrass
myself and so then he proceeds to say
listen I was supposed to come we're
having a jam session you know do you and
the band want to come back and you know
jam and I was like yeah we want to come
back and jam and
the rest was history the rest was this
on the Minneapolis no he was in L.A oh
so what he would do is and he was one of
the best like party throwers that you
will ever know I mean we have seen uh
some Chappelle skits that I mean I don't
know how true those guys are all right
but my interactions with him have always
been like
can play guitar and party like
till the sun comes up seven in the
morning I didn't leave that night me and
my band we did not leave till seven in
the morning so this was a jam session
that didn't end until oh wow seven in
the morning it was it was just it was
amazing and he was just talking to me he
was like he was telling me everything he
loved about what he had seen me do and I
was like
I didn't even know you looked on the
internet right like you know who I am
that's wild I'm just like I would just
think you would be somewhere
yeah in in some sort of Castle right you
know with no Wi-Fi right with no Wi-Fi
but he was very aware and I always tell
people the best thing about him is like
even though he was mysterious he never
let his mystery get in the way of his
mentorship he was always like
wanting to give advice and you know open
up if you have any questions about the
business and didn't even charge me
anything to be on my album give me the
most value you have three pretty serious
mentors Prince Puff Daddy Big Boy give
me three lessons each of them
wow um
Prince is like obviously like the
blueprint for
um
you know owning your you know
like as an artist not being afraid to
fight for what you were old on the
business side of things right
um and also creating a blueprint
um
that felt so free and
you could do anything you know and just
and just also speaking with him
he just always reminded me that
musically there was nothing that I could
not do
and I think with puff
who has been a person of his word
um you know we have a partnership
together when he had first heard me and
doing the science fiction singing about
that and you know
doing doing whatever I wanted to do as
an artist creatively he always said like
I don't want to mess that up right I
just want the rest of the world to see
what I saw what I just saw tonight I
just want to help so I called him at a
really good time and
um you know he's just always been an
advocate for for me if I need to have
like
any business conversations I can I know
I can call him and you know listen to
him as well and then he just taught me
to just like be a fan of your own [__]
too you know promote your stuff if you
love it you got to promote your [__]
yeah yeah you worked hard and I think
with big boy big boy was just I mean I
got to give it to him you know the
reason why puffy even knew about me was
because of the work
that big boy gave to me I was singing
back up I was also on Idlewild you know
he was really really promoting me with
purple ribbon he taught me the
importance of I think staying with
family like staying with the people for
like a little little bit Yeah my lip but
I always had my label but I would do
Partnerships so it's like purple ribbon
yeah so it was you was it was a Bubba
spark yes
look at you a lot of people do not
remember killing my killer
Mike's new album which is coming out
tonight is it that one is it it's not
out yet okay I listened to it a couple
weeks ago okay it's incredible one of
the greatest rappers of all time oh I
gotta I gotta listen to it yeah it's
incredible who has the best parties
Prince or Diddy oh that's so tough ah
because both of them know how to [__]
they're legendary different it's
different
I wonder if they I never went to a party
where they did it together the world
yeah it would explode like princess
daddy in the same party man because
you're gonna get music from like both of
them are going to play the best music
have the most beautiful people there
good food
um
I don't know oh princess oh listen I
which party would you rather I believe
the fifth I believe okay uh because it's
good for different reasons like for
different reasons so both both I'll say
both I like that yeah what's up y'all we
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our good friends at my
bookie that's right it is NBA Finals you
gotta Hammer the Nuggets I don't know
they might sweep the heat I would look
at the
like serious odds on that go to my
bookie right now let's get some money
man all right baseball of course is in
full effect we got Stanley Cup finals
NFL seasons on the way sign up at
mybookie.ag right now use the promo code
bootleg and you will get that first
deposit bonus
all right look I don't care where you're
at you can go to mybookie.ag Let's
gamble on some sports they got the
casino you can do live Blackjack you can
do live roulette craps you could do all
kinds of slots and of course bet on the
NBA Finals bet on the NHL uh Stanley Cup
finals crazy shots of the Vegas golden
knights that's what I'm rooting for and
of course baseball season man all right
so look right now mybookie.ag use that
promo code bootleg uh and sign up when
you do use uh that promo code they're
going to give you a first deposit bonus
straight to your account free money all
right mybookie.ag go do that also got to
give a shout out to our family at Blue
chew that's right ladies and gentlemen
it's getting hot outside that means
I don't know what that means it's just
hot so I feel like when it's hot people
want to [__] more right so you know
fellas if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it happens to the best of us
I'm sure maybe you are old maybe you are
dealing with stress at work maybe you
don't want to sleep with the same lady
that you're married to over and over
need a little extra motivation to get
that thing stayed up you know what I
mean go to uhboochu.com use the promo
code bootleg and they'll send it
straight to your door three-month supply
of Bluetooth for free all right now does
Bluetooth work yes it does you're gonna
get a free month supply to be able to
see for yourself boozer.com promo code
bootleg uh now if you don't know what it
is it is the same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis but in a chewable form
and you do not have to go to a doctor's
appointment all right you do everything
online you don't have to go sit at a
doctor's office and talk to some old man
in a lab coat about your dick issues not
necessary anymore in 2023 all right so
go to Bluetooth sign up with that promo
code bootleg get a month supply for free
let's get back to the interviews
um it's obviously pride month and you
are someone who's a non-binary person
yeah
um thank you I think that we are in like
a weird uh area of like education when
it comes to like people kind of being
ignorant to what that means and I think
that like there are certain people who
have a hard time adjusting to certain
pronouns and can you kind of just like
if because you uh you also are your she
slash hers one of your pronouns and then
also they them and free ass [__]
free ass [__] the most
important one yes
um for you though like can you kind of I
feel like there should be some etiquette
out there for like people who are still
kind of adjusting especially like in the
hip-hop world I feel like this is all
new like
um why it's important to make sure you
respect someone's pronouns yeah
yeah I mean
you know we are all here having this
Earth Human Experience and we want to
um
be happy in that and be happy in our
identities you know even if I have the
saying embrace the things that make you
unique even if it makes others
uncomfortable and I just live by that
and and and
I My Hope Is that
as we're having this Earth experience
everybody can understand that we come
from different walks of life some people
are at different evolutions and
discoveries on who they are uh and just
because you may not understand anything
doesn't mean that you shouldn't respect
it right so I think in terms of me being
non-binary
um I think I was not binary a long time
ago I just didn't have the language and
so that's it's important that's why it's
so important to even have certain words
and and a community putting you know the
words to how you're feeling I mean
Prince said it best I'm not a woman I'm
not a man I'm something that you'll
never understand
and I always identify with that word you
know with those words Prince might have
been the first non-binary person listen
he might have been listen so I feel all
of me you know I feel
I feel all of me I honor all of me and
um I see my
um
my spirit and and me outside of the
binary constructs of
I think that's what I think a lot of
people don't understand what it means
right it's right they can Google it it's
very definitely it's it's out it's out
there you know the Google as my uh older
older I would say
I always tell people too like if you're
um so wrapped up on calling somebody the
wrong thing because it makes you feel
better but it makes someone else feel
bad about themselves yeah it's like how
much of an inconvenience is it to like
respect a word like yeah like you're not
asking somebody to like yeah do anything
crazy like just call somebody what they
prefer to be called because if you if
you don't it could potentially you know
make someone feel bad you know yeah yeah
you know compassion uh I think also
education is important yeah you know I
think once we get more educated on um on
what it means and you you really have
conversations with folks you will
realize you may have more in common with
them than you think and
um yeah my hope is that that's why I
love being that's why I love music
that's why I love art that's why I love
making it because what I'm able to do
and what we're able to do is bring
people together right and have these
conversations at concerts you're
learning different things and you know
and I love and happy Pride I don't know
when this is coming out but this is June
good to be out you know I think we're
dropping the money yeah I love that
we're also in a space where we're
celebrating us unapologetically as you
can see and and sometimes that triggers
and it has as we see with the laws that
are being made right now it's crazy
against you know our my trans family and
lgbtqi plus Community being a part of
that Community imagine me not having the
platform that I have and having to sort
of live in a small town and you know
everybody supports uh anti-uh uh uh
lgbtqia plus bills and anti you know uh
trans bills and even being black right
now you know they're taking out black
history in Florida yeah the Santa's a
wild boy man you know horrible horrible
person so you know we have to
is serious like respecting people's it
all matters yes it's funny too because
they're like like I don't want to say
there because I don't like to I don't
like to group anybody in but a guy like
the scientists for example will scream
about how
everything's getting censored like and
everything's like cancel culture but
then you're canceling like yeah like you
know like black history like in a state
it's kind of crazy it's like
yeah people politicians are are crazy
you have dochi on the album who's one of
my favorite new artists obviously she's
incredible she's incredible yeah
she's a I I I did radio in Tampa so it's
dope to see uh her doing her thing but
she's a person too and she's like very
high level creative like I saw her when
she first time with TD she did like this
like industry performance and it was so
crazy what was it like working with her
all of that like we have kindred spirits
and you know I just as soon as I heard
her music I loved her and I felt her
spirit and then when we met she just
told me how much of an inspiration I was
to her and and watching me gave her you
know a lot of um confidence to just do
her you know
um and you see that you see that she is
somebody who's tapped in you know to uh
her Innovation and what makes her unique
um and I love that about her and and it
was beautiful we were in the studio we
had so much fun making phenomenal like
that song
because when I heard persuasive I was
like oh I love this song I love it and
so when we got together when I was
working on my project I was like oh you
would be perfect for this sort of of of
song and I didn't even tell her I played
her like five songs I don't even tell
her this is a song I want you to be on
she heard phenomenal she's like she
jumped up said hey so she's she's just
humble creative a beautiful person she
came over last night to celebrate with
me oh nice yeah she I didn't even know
she was coming she surprised me so
that's dope
um for you did you have any idea that
you were gonna break Twitter when you uh
Flash the crowd on your performance
because you you own Twitter for about a
week oh my God no I did not I literally
was at my friend's party living my life
as I always do and you know I did not I
I was having a good time I felt like I
was in a safe space right and that's it
I was honoring exactly how I was feeling
so yeah because like did you I mean you
had to have some sort of idea
this is gonna be on the internet a
little bit I was very shocked that I
mean when after after
I realized that there were so many
cameras you know because I try not to
live my life like I'm Janelle Monae
there are cameras let me let me let me
not yeah and and these and the party
that I was at was uh the same party that
inspired my album so I know a lot of the
people who were there and you know
they've been to to my place and we've
created a safe space with everyday
people and with Wonderland and in our
parties and so
um it didn't really come out until like
that video was older it was old so
somebody was like well let me now
capitalize and that's the world we live
in yeah let me capitalize like it was
nobody posted anything safe space and
then when they sort of Saw
um
I think my visual that I put out they
were like oh well while we're here I saw
her laugh you know last week yeah yeah
but it's all love free the nipple free
the nips free the nipple I mean Rick
Ross has freed his nipple I support him
you're right about that D'Angelo when he
did Untitled he wasn't freed his nipple
you know that from behind that piano and
free the nipple you know I can go on and
on DJ Khaled just freed his nipples many
times right DJ Khaled you know we
support free the nipple right for all
people I agree yeah this is a double
standard that t-shirt wrong
yeah and so it helped with the promotion
because now everybody's like I mean you
were trending like yeah you know listen
I live my life I think I never think
like oh this is going to get them
talking I'm having an earth experience
and of honoring all of me I love it
that's it that's all I can do
um give me if you're on an island
stranded for 365 days you can only bring
Five albums with you on an iPod oh now
stop it first of all an iPod I have not
heard that word you're not gonna have
Wi-Fi because you're going to be on an
island you're right you're right here's
your phone so I have to use well my iPod
die though though that's a hey okay I
don't know right okay it's like let's
not get too specific about this keep it
keep it
she's like is there going to be sewage
well I'm definitely taking the age of
pleasure okay because I know that we
made that project to be on an island to
be on an island to transport me and if I
need a soundtrack to that to to that
that experience that I want to have
um
oh okay I have to take
some prints so maybe I'll take Purple
Rain all right
um he has so many albums I gotta take
some Stevie okay I gotta have some
comfort shout out to Stevie intervisions
or music of my mind one of those
um
I also would probably take just
soundtrack
um
I would take uh
some Harold bud
he has an album Harold Budd which is
like it puts me in a super meditative
space
um one more oh God this is tough this is
really really tough I don't even know
why I'm answering this I just feel like
I'm gonna be like why didn't I say that
album
um
what else would I take what else do I
what about give me a hip-hop one oh okay
um
maybe I might take
maybe I'll take the love below okay
speaker box take the double disc that's
it yeah that's a nice speaker box
exactly I will take that because that's
like I remember wanting to make
like music like fun creative I remember
that was that that helped me tap into to
to my own uniqueness uh you mentioned
Stevie Wonder uh Stephen wonders
obviously obviously a fan of yours when
you meet Stevie Wonder what is that like
he said like I feel like he's got like
one of those people kind of like Prince
they feel like they might have an aura
you see around them for sure for sure
but also very funny such a jokester such
a trickster will say whatever's on his
mind
um I'm like you should let people see
more of this side of you because people
do put he I mean his music is like
holy you know
um he's the blueprint for a lot of a lot
of music
but just to like he was on my last
project dirty computer and um just I
recorded him
talking we had just a conversation and
we were just talking about all the
heaviness this is somebody who's lived
in multiple Generations you know
somebody who was here uh pre-integration
and and got a chance to usher in
um
so revolutions you know with his music
and he just has stories that nobody has
right he probably does there's not a lot
of people who are walking this Earth who
could tell stories like him
yeah just a beautiful spirit and and um
yeah I love him I love him all right so
the album is out everybody go get it age
of pleasure any did we talk about how I
did the album how'd you do it okay so my
friends I was talking about that same
party everyday people they could not
um find a spot and so I offered our spot
Wonderland uh in L.A we have a spot in
Atlanta and now in L.A there's like
creative spaces yeah creative space you
know Studio indoor outdoor Vibes and
um
I offered our spot and I was like let's
do like maybe 100 people
um test everybody is doing the pandemic
and the people who were at the party
again most beautiful brown and black
people from all over the globe from
Africa South Africa Ghana Nigeria
um Jamaica the Caribbeans New York L.A
Midwest like all of us together in a
safe space
and in the pandemic when you hadn't been
around people
reintegrating super weird it was just
like but it was like oh this is life
like this is what we fight to protect
right this is what we're missing that's
what we're missing I don't realize
you're missing it until yeah until you
and I was like okay I know I want to
make a soundtrack I want to make a
soundtrack to this lifestyle because I
want to see that Joy you know I
oftentimes our safe spaces
um
are
police come in shut it down
um and and to see us having that Joy
complete strangers getting to know each
other feeling so free uh was something
that I I only dream of and I always want
for everybody and so I just started
making the music
for the parties that was it I said tell
my DJ don't say it's me I'm gonna make
like two to three songs just play them
in the mix play it and if people are not
shazamming it's not going on the album
if people are going to go sit down it
will not make the album and that's how I
made um the age of pleasure with my
friends for my friends got to stop the
interview to tell you about our family
as Odd Socks that's right the most
comfortable socks in the world ladies
and gentlemen uh go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg calf or bootleg both promo codes
work you'll save 20 out at checkout uh
20 off these are the Odd Socks Basics
all right now you can get like a pack of
all black pack of all whites of course
they got all kind of crazy licenses WWE
Cheech and Chong they got Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles they got SpongeBob
SquarePants bruh look they got the
SpongeBob SquarePants Krabby Patty
draws
yeah now you don't want crabs but you do
want Mr crab's underwear because these
are fire all right so look go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code uh bootleg save 20 off a
checkout and uh yeah listen trust me
when I say most comfortable socks you'll
ever put on your [__] feet
and the most comfortable boxer briefs
what are we talking about man all right
autotoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off of checkout great gift and
and just treat yourself all right also
got a shout out to our family a King
Palm now if you guys don't know about
ping pong kingpong is all natural baby
yes all right we're talking about the
leader when it comes to uh tobacco-free
natural organic Leaf wraps if you're a
smoker a totor a straight west coaster
you know what I'm saying whatever you're
into King Palms they got it for you
what's great about
um these these are like one of the best
uh products that they sell now this is a
terpene infused tobacco-free leaf
and what's dope is you stuff your flour
into it
and then you press on the thingy you
know what I'm saying
and then you got flavor I'm going to
show you what it looks like when it's
stuffed
with some great tree from Jardin of
course
ah look at that
right get that thing stuffed up
the tip has got that flavor in it uh
wherever you're at man make sure you
check out the uh
um you know they got the smoke shops
they got those on lock they got
7-Elevens on lock we only smoking out of
King Palms baby you already know what it
is and if you go to
kingpoms.com
kingpom.com kingpom.com
and you use the promo code bootleg Kev
you will save 50 off at checkout
half off at checkout fifty percent off
if you go to kingpom.com and use that
promo code the promo code is down below
go run it up try some of these flavors
too man the peach pineapple the
Strawberry Shortcake they just got so
much going on there's also all kinds of
dope smoking accessories you can get
half off y'all what are we talking about
save 50 off kingpom.com promo code below
it's either bootleg or bootleg have them
these promo codes got my head hurt try
both of them all right one of them get
you 50 off God damn it anyway let's get
back to the interview so you were
testing out records in real time yeah
without anyone knowing that's what was
going on without people knowing and I
was just in the corner with a drink like
oh my God yeah and then that's I tested
all my songs flow water slide
um you know champagne shade lipstick
lover just like that and and
um it's just it feels really good uh to
be able to sort of have it out because
I've been living with it for so long me
and my friends like a great way to like
it I mean it's the same way like when
people go try to like they're in Atlanta
they go to the strip club to try to test
the records you know it's like you want
to see see how people react in real time
because the right people I got super
specific about that too because
oftentimes like we want everybody and I
was like no let me get specific I if my
friends [__] with it that's it yeah and
it's like a genuine reaction if they
don't know what it is or know that it's
you exactly you'll be able to see like
an unbiased yeah exactly that's pretty
great how many songs didn't get shazamed
you know maybe a couple you know we will
not talk about them we'll develop those
and maybe they'll become something but
I'm so proud of what we've been able to
do and shout out to Nate rocket wonder
and Sensei Bueno and Nana they were with
me providing that safe space you know as
I you know evolve it's it's a it you and
they kept the fun in it because I was
like I have to make sure that when I'm
in the studio I'm not overthinking I'm
not
um thinking about everybody I'm getting
specific and I'm having a good time you
know the journey is just as important as
the result I was going to say when you
record because like you know you'll hear
like certain artists just have like hard
drives or just unreleased music like
and then there's other artists who are
very specific and intentional when they
record music and they take a little bit
more time do you like how big is the
pool of Music you're pulling from to
pick to put on the album
I didn't have like oh I did 20 songs
like I I I knew the sounds right I knew
like what I want a new float I wanted
that to be sort of the Cornerstone the
entry point into the album I knew I
wanted the sounds to be super horny this
is the age of pleasure
um I knew that I wanted to
you know because we were listening to
afrobeats at the parties we were
listening to reggae Caribbean we were
listening to I'm a piano we were
listening to all of that so that
naturally seeped over into the sounds so
once I knew the musical bed I then would
take themes like lipstick lover for
instance that's really really my life
you know being the person either put
lipstick on somebody's neck or somebody
put lipstick on my neck and I was like
that's the song I looked in the mirror
saw the red Prince that's the song
that's a song yeah that's it you write
about those things that happen so once I
got specific about again
who was for how I wanted people to feel
it was easy it was it was like water so
you'll go from just an idea of like
looking in the mirror seeing lipstick
and be like okay yeah there's a song I
Gotta make yeah oh well speaking of
instead of doing 20 50 songs I actually
have a spreadsheet where I wrote down 50
Concepts oh between 50 and 80 Concepts
so it'll be like a spreadsheet of like
ideas like that yeah you'd be like you
know what I feel like I can go somewhere
with this yeah like ooh the you know she
kissed me on my neck lipstick prince I
gotta write about that but you know I
would just things that happened at the
party I like the way that I saw him look
at her you know that's that's a line
like I'm just going watching everything
and you know as Nina Simone would say an
artist's job is to reflect the times and
a time was had the time was had it was I
mean you've learned from the best yeah
Prince and puffy what are we talking
about okay we talk about Grace Jones
though let's talk about the women okay
Grace Jones is on this project yeah I
mean she taught me so much you know even
as I'm on my own journey of honoring all
of me
um you know she's done a lot of what
I've already done in her own way and so
it was just great to have her in the
studio I spent 72 hours with her wow and
she recorded a lot of stuff and so you
have her on there speaking French you
have Nia Long I was going to ask the Nia
Long that's on the album is the Nia Long
Nia Long oh Nia Long the one and the
only one yeah she came over and recorded
and she always like she's amazing yeah I
mean obviously shout out to Friday you
know yeah exactly that helped and and uh
boys in the hood I mean she's yeah she's
one of them she is icons when you're
growing up yeah yeah he's an 80s baby
along was one of the leaders yeah like
Nia Holly for me too that's how I knew I
was like oh I'm definitely queer yeah
Nia Long is my girlfriend did Nia long
was she the one who made you realize you
were attracted to women definitely she's
the first I I don't know maybe not the
first but
she confirmed it so Nia Long confirmed I
could get down with chicks for sure for
me yeah when I saw her I was like but
then I didn't know if I wanted to be her
or be with her she's one of those people
where you look at her and you're like I
want to be just like that and obviously
I am inspired by her Which movie was it
that you saw her in that made you be
like Jesus uh boys in the hood
um
and then Love Jones for sure I mean come
on yeah you know but I'm so happy to
have her as a friend and
um you know like a big sister and you
know even went down to when I was
releasing my press photos before I
released them she you know I let her see
them and she was like oh you should you
should release that like this is the one
you coming out the water like this is it
so there were a lot of wonderful women
um from dochi to Amore to Grace to Nia
to Sister Nancy which is dope I was
gonna say it's also dope to see sister
Nancy because obviously sister Nancy's a
oh gee in the reggae world like
man like what is that like how do you
get a hold of sister Nancy I just
reached out like who do you reach out to
who did we
I just had my I had somebody on my team
who knew her nephew right and then we
got in touch with her and when I got on
the phone with her
she knew a lot about me and I was like
what I love you and I just her story is
so cool you know her during the time
that she came up reggae DJs were not
for what women reggae DJ specifically
women who DJ'd during that era were not
really accepted you know they were told
her family told her to go do this you
need to be doing this and she was like
no this is what I'm gonna do and now you
can't go to a house party or a regular
party in general without playing bomba I
was going to say she's one of and also
like one of the most sampled songs ever
ever yeah you can and so to get her to
do some original stuff right was just
like
just a dream come true you know
incredible and so yeah well the body of
work is out yes go stream it uh go
download it go buy it I'm sure you got
some crazy merch is it out or is it yeah
merge go to jmonay.com
[Applause]
[Music]
yes I'll be touring the end of August
through the middle of October
um we are we are all North American
tours right uh tour stops now and
um
I haven't announced Europe yet you know
who you're taking on the road with you
I'm I'm still picking because I'm gonna
do some opening acts in different
markets that makes sense yeah I think
jidenna may do some dates as well so
it'll be great it's gonna feel it's it's
a movement it's a pleasure the theaters
or TV screens soon that you that you
have in the in the pipeline yeah I'm
working on uh a TV show about the
Josephine Baker who was also an
inspiration is also an inspiration for
me in her time as a spy during the
French Resistance a lot of people don't
know like they see the banana skirt and
you know obviously she was super
liberated and she had moved to France
because America wouldn't even let her
perform in some of the clubs and I'm not
even I don't know who that is you don't
know who Josephine Baker oh my God like
the freest Spirit you know she was doing
that for the French Resistance but she
was an incredible performer as well like
an artist yes beautiful like while being
alive
oh yeah it's gonna be great have you as
a streaming network uh yeah well we're
partnering with a24 a24
yeah
uncut gems yes by the way Moonlight one
of my favorite movies like ever such an
incredible movie it was my first movie
was that like did you understand like
being in that movie how
one it obviously was critically
acclaimed but it also felt like a very
important step into kind of just like
normalizing like
being gay kind of like in the urban
community a little bit absolutely like
did you realize that when you guys were
filming that movie when I read the
script you know it just brought tears to
my eyes just thinking about how so many
people were going to be seen that that
probably
would never have imagined anybody
telling their story you know from the
ghettos of Miami to Atlanta you know
deep down south around the world like
little black boys would would feel seen
and it was just great to be an ally
um you know playing an ally in the in
the film as Teresa a lot of people I can
tell you the number of people that come
up and like because of Teresa I know how
to
be an ally and be supportive to my
younger right you know sibling or cousin
or
um you know younger person in my life
and so yeah I didn't know that it was
gonna it just meant something to me and
so I'm happy I've been some to a lot of
other people because it wasn't movie of
the year right yeah yeah I got
um yeah film a movie movie of the year
or what do you call it is it uh and the
war goes to the best picture best
picture best picture yeah that was a
whole debacle but we don't even go into
that because remember they called
somebody else you remember that and then
we had to go up yeah that was a weird
year yeah do you get one of those at
home no unfortunately but you know I
always wonder how that works because I
know it's in my heart I think they're
going to start giving like engineers and
people like as they should yeah like if
if you're in the movie you can get an
Oscar come on Oscars send me my costume
writer and the director the director
sometimes I think the producer I don't
know I need to like check Oscar on your
mantle listen it'll give me something
more I you know what we'll get one
actually if I get one or if I don't I
love the work like I love I love me even
if moon like never got nominated I'm so
proud that that was mine shout out to
a24 they put out some amazing content
yeah beef beef was them right yeah I
haven't seen beef it's pretty wild but
everything everywhere all at once
that one definitely the best movie in
the last like four or five years like
that changed the game so good yeah so
good all right well I appreciate you
coming through thank you for having me
go get the new album yeah I'm looking
forward to everything else you got
coming on the way to work coming soon
good to see you too hey appreciate y'all
watching another interview brought to
you by our good Folks at hardean now
listen y'all when you're in Las Vegas
you get in that [__] Uber you land at
the airport hit that taxi tell him to
take you to hard Dean the number one
premium cannabis dispensary in the
[__] world y'all I'm telling you you
walk in they treat you like a king or a
queen or whatever you're into all right
they got the craziest selection to
premium cannabis you'll see period
anywhere let alone in Las Vegas but just
anywhere all right not only can you go
get the best tree you won't get the best
experience the best customer service the
best bud tenders you walk in the hard
Dean and that [__] just smells amazing
they got their own [__] scent
literally you get into my car I got a
bottle of it I'd my car smells like
Harding because it's just the best
[__] place
um go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to their
website
hardinglasvegas.com all right when you
go you're in Vegas you pull up tell them
I sent you they're gonna take care of
you the right way all right look they
got these things in there man these Moon
Rock uh pre-rolls that I just had that
just absolutely melted my face off
shout out to hardine all right you gotta
go [__] with hard Dean man Harding
underscore Las Vegas uh thank you all
man I love these guys they're like
family to us and uh hey we're gonna drop
another interview soon if you're
watching this you're at the end of the
interview though much love